Xin
Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học Đỗ
Bảo Nam Vlog video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo
Nam đấu sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách hiện
thước đo cho buốt Thìn mọi phiên bản
để hiện thước đo cho nuốt khi bạn chỉ
cần thực hiện theo hai bước mà bạn nhìn
thấy trên màn hình
nếu như bạn đã đổi đơn vị đo từ inch
sang Cm thì bạn có thể bỏ qua bút thứ
nhất mà chuyển ngay sang Bước 2 ở đây Đỗ
Bảo Nam vào lúc sẽ thực hiện nhanh từ 11
bước thứ nhất đổi đơn vị đo từ inch sang
Cm
Bạn kích vào file trên menu
sau đó trợ option
tiếp theo bạn kích vào ven
và bạn tìm đến
phần đơn vị ở đây đơn vị ra máy in bạn
chỉ cần chọn là xe Ừ
Ok
như vậy Mình vừa thực hiện xong bước thứ
nhất đổi đơn vị đo từ inch sang Cm
tiếp theo đôi bàn abraxas sang bước thứ
hai hiện thước đo trong Word
bạn thích vào view trên menu
sau đó bạn tích vào aller
thì ngay lập tức Bạn đã nhìn thấy anh
thức đo được hiển thị ở phía trên và ở
bên cạnh của file which
như vậy Ở video vừa rồi đâu Bảo Nam vừa
chia sẻ nhanh như bạn cách hiện thước đo
trong Word Nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần
được hỗ trợ bạn ai comment trực tiếp ở
phía dưới video này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo
dõi video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở
các video tiếp theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nay A và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ đó bà Nam bóp Đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ vào Nam vlogs
Xin cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam được
và truy cập website đâu Bảo Nam club.com
hoặc kênh YouTube gỗ bàn ăn bóp để xem
thêm các video gũi như thủ thuật máy
tính tay Proshow của dơ
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bàn ăn một lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết thôi mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp mày bạn ở các video tiếp theo